Greece wants less austerity austerity is
a word but you can measure it through
the primary surplus ratio this is
basically what a country saves divided
by its GDP if it's positive you're
saving money but you're inflicting pain
in pursuit of some future gold
you're being austere Greece's bailout
calls for a primary surplus ratio of
4.5% this is to force it to make hard
decisions about budgets but according to
the IMF Greece would need to hold that
number even higher at 7.2 percent for a
decade if it actually plans to pay down
its debt to eurozone standards there is
very little reason to believe that this
is possible the last 10 years Greece has
run from negative to very negative but
last year it notched a positive 3%
encouraging right but take the eurozone
as a whole since the Euro began all
those countries together hit 3.6 percent
only once in 2000 and now it's back
below zero
let's go broader and farther back since
1974 only three countries period have
averaged greater than 5 percent for more
than 10 years Singapore Norway and
Belgium which spent the 90s trying to
meet the eurozone standards Greece might
have considered doing the same but
that's water under the bridge according
to the Center for Economic Policy
Research countries that hold a primary
surplus over time tend to have
consolidated political control by a
single party Greece has that for now
kind of these countries tend to have a
high level of debt which encourages them
to save Greece has that too but they're
also likely to have a positive balance
of payments that's more money coming in
than out and they're likely to save at a
time of economic expansion like Belgium
in the 1990s not like now so can Greece
make it to 4.5%
as the current agreement demands
probably not can Greece make it to 7.2
percent and pay its debt down no way no
how yes when pigs fly
you